welcome back to the which answered the
show alright welcome back to New York
City or we're calling a little bit of an
Omaha here a little bit of a little
inaudible because he was gonna join us
in the next segment he's gonna join us
for the rest of the hour now which is
great we just figured we'll sit him
right down since he did hand Michael
Irvin a playoff loss back in the day as
we mentioned Michael Irvin still here on
the Rich Eisen show put that Mike lots
of you there Mike even though you your
voice definitely carries Barry Sanders
Pro Football Hall of Famer here on the
show how are you bury a rich doing great
man doing great thanks for having me so
I just figured I bring up that playoff
yeah win that I've that's the second
time I've done that to Mike now do you
know I love the fact that you started to
show off of that because I think that's
like the most important thing to talk
about anybody you think obviously I know
but not much happened after that you
bring that might be a sore spot that's
why Barry's head to Luke I walked away
right it would have certainly been nice
to have a few rings well you got a Hall
of Fame ring we know that I did they we
got that for you right there which is
good right
so let's talk let's talk running backs
real quick we got obviously one of the
all-time greats right here Irv what can
you tell me about Zeke Elliott right now
listen let me tell you something this
would trust me out here and Barry I want
to hear your thoughts on it cuz you know
now it's always everybody's keep saying
you know you can win with any running
back or you're gonna win with a number
of running backs
it runs me crazy that when you're at a
top god when they're 25 other teams out
here who had who's running back by
committee they wish they had an easy qle
so now you're bringing his talent down
to the rest of the crew instead of
telling 25 teams to go find you a Barry
Sanders or is Thank You Elliot you see
it blows my mind
when people are doing that
these are unique dudes man I was there I
saw in it when ma came in I saw all the
running backs before Amon and and we
were going nowhere until you got there
there are certain type of dudes that are
different dudes how do you see and how
do you feel about how they are treating
the running backs now well Zeke
especially right Zeke especially me and
you can see it in this production you
see it in the plays that he makes he has
it he has a pretty good line and
obviously has a good quarterback but
every running back you know can't make
the moves and the yardage the seat makes
you know even even not just running it
in the passing game so syke special but
no it's it's a little bit offensive you
know the way you say it's been devalued
right because when you're in the meeting
room and you watching the games and you
understand okay this is what the players
the play is called this is
responsibilities you you know who like
the real players are right and and
sometimes you know obviously the
quarterbacks get a lot of the credit
sometimes well-deserved sometimes not
um but you have a player like Zeke and
he makes it easy for everyone the bottom
line he makes it easier at for everyone
so he's an easy unique talent well in
terms of Zeke - it's not the running
it's not the past catching out of the
backfield it's the past protection and
he came off the campus in Columbus ready
to do it as a professional more than
perhaps any running back that I've seen
his last 10 15 years and how many you
know that's how Romo broke his back once
is because a running back missed a
blocking assignment so that's just
another ability so what is Jerry up to
the durability we're talking about we're
talking about and we're talking about
Andrew luxury these guys get hit what do
you cite three four times a game and it
take a couple runs
Andy mace and he still plays every play
any initiates contact to initiate what I
saw when his rookie year when he looked
up cam chance I said oh my god
he was not in a pre-season oh my god
that's a different dude right there that
was it
I was a big fan from that moment all
because cam Chancellor makes you check
your courage he makes you check your
courage and Zeke me Zeke went out there
my little no in the world I would be
scared of kam chancellor man I was so
happy we missed each other in years a
lot of other guys after that all right
like I say he initiates contact right
obviously has you know that track speed
who can break long ones but he's also
very physical almost in the mindset of a
Walter Payton type guy so the kid is
impressive
so what I'll repeat the question there
yeah you and I understand why you'd lost
you would lost but what is gerry up to I
don't know man I'm calling the game
Thursday night I'm pulling Jerry aside
and I'll share I'm gonna tell Jerry like
listen man I understand what you're
trying to do with with everybody so you
want to put that in the top three or
four quarterback that's a great position
for that that's still in the $30,000,000
you want to put them are in the top two
or three receivers that's going to be a
great position because Michael Thomas
just move that number to almost
20,000,000 but Zeke Zeke is different
and you should if there is no putting
him in the top two or three he should be
the I don't care if you guys can get
these egos out the way and you're given
$1 more $1 more and I remember having
that conversation with him about Emmitt
when I say go give him $1 more than
Thurman Thomas at the time you had got a
deal and Thurman got a new deal and then
him it wanted to be the top guys just
give him a dollar more let's get this
done let's get it done and get it out
the way and another thing how many times
I hear people saying well Zeke has no
leverage stop saying that
stop saying that he does have leverage
and what a win a Super Bowl you're not
going to hit a Super Bowl without him
that's his leverage and that's why Jerry
keeps inching as they say in the report
inching toward our girlies number
because the season keeps inching close
to starting and he wants to win a Super
Bowl
he has leverage and right now his
killing is killing us that he's not in
camp it's killing us that he's not good
because it's going to take time it'll
take time when he gets in camp to really
get a rhythm well yeah take time I mean
you know you certainly need a few weeks
with your line you know and with the
rest of offense just time and was really
even if he's in there and done that with
this line well it depends on what he's
doing obviously you know it depends on
what he's what he's doing now you know
he's working out whatever but but
certainly just just getting into game
shape right no there's nothing else you
can do to mimic that on your own
so you know but but at the same time
after I'd have to you know you know
admit that hey I had my share of
holdouts during my career sometime it
just calls for that you know and I think
Zeke you know and it's a person's
decision so so he has to do what's right
for him
you know we saw what happened with
Le'Veon last year you know we hope it
doesn't come to that as a lion as you
know as a Lions fan and it doesn't
matter that much to me if he holds out
but you know he has to do what's right
for him himself but yeah
he certainly has leverage you know
because they know I mean hey look like I
was talking about Jerry know who the
players are right and obviously he's a
tough negotiator right and so he has to
he has to see what kind of businessman
um
Zakia's you know and how convicted he is
but but I'm sure at some point the next
few weeks they'll get something Amari if
I'm Amari and I I'm telling ya get this
done because this can fake these [ __ ] my
numbers now because now with Zeke I can
go get my numbers I know my deals coming
without Zeke this thing doesn't go well
didn't you looking at me for my numbers
too you know my contract that's coming
up I mean I'm like you got it I just
think he's the catalyst on their team
and they need him badly
Michael Irvin and Barry Sanders together
for just a couple more minutes and then
Barry's gonna finish up the hour just
solo here you know I had Marshall Faulk
on the show you know Marshall came in
last Thursday yeah I saw the billboard
they got it running your fault training
zql yeah I was trying to make him trying
to
compute what he said he said he couldn't
and he lost the bet with Zeke is that he
said trying to get him into into
football shape but he made he made the
point that what Zeke is asking for is
potentially less than half of what
they're gonna play pay DAC annually and
that in the grand scheme of things but
as Jerry pointed out when they signed
Jaylon Smith there is less pie it's what
he said there's now there's net there is
now less good at that stuff so ask the
poll question of these two guys right
here Chris Brockman before you say
goodbye to ERV and then hang out with
Barry Sanders for to finish out the rest
of the hour
okay guys which is more likely this NFL
season likely this NFL season Gronk
returns to the Pats Zeke signs before
week one or both Michael you all wrong
signs before week one I do
that's why Jerry's injured he's inching
closer in itching more I mean I do
believe he's going son it's just a whole
mentality you can't you're asking guys
to be all-in and and you're not doing
what you need to do to get guys all in
that mentality will permeate the locker
room I definitely think he'll get it
done before week 1 ok what are you how
close are we how close is is that
numbers was we well the latest thing is
that Zeke has been told according to a
report in Dallas Inchon credits it's
more than levian Belle's annual salary
but less than girlies he would not be
the number one guy in terms of
guaranteed dollars as well but the last
report latest report is he's inching
closer to him let me tell you what Jared
Cook jr. tried this when Tim Braun was
the highest-paid and I was negotiating
with the meet he'll try this too now
what Zeke you know and take home money
since they have state taxes in
California you're really the highest
paid stop anything you negotiate
[Laughter]
do you think ronk might come back today
he said he would physically be able to
play you might have missed this he said
today basically it's just mentally he's
not there talking about how much pain he
was in
took the joy out of the game and that's
the reason why he retired on the Super
Bowl what do you think yeah I don't know
that he will come back this season but
but maybe next year okay I would Bank on
next year what do you think earth well I
think we're grunts going to learn is
that a lot of things are more fun if
when they're the sidekick the football
now you don't have a football and you
take all those things that were fun as a
sidekick are real fun as a primary and
you just don't get the same thing you
don't even get the same crowd or the
same reaction because you're no longer
the tide in oh so so I do believe he's
going to miss the game grunts our
fun-loving God and all of it comes off
of the football so III think he is going
to miss it I don't know if he can get
himself back right to come back and play
but I guarantee you he'll miss the game
well I think about it I think for sure
you can't read any tea leaves but he
will no doubt in my mind be there in
Gillette two Sundays from now when
Sunday Night Football as the banner
raising he'll be part of the banner
raising I'm sure he'll be there I'm sure
they're Patriots would want him there
I'm sure he wants to be with his
teammates when they celebrate the the
title that he helped win say he'll see
that and then he'll watch them play and
this will be the first time he maybe
starts thinking about the juices flowing
and then potentially you know how
ultimate let me walk let me walk through
this year through this then you know you
know the Patriots offense might be a
little bit out of sync see this right
here on a second now you page us up and
you know the people's defense annually
takes a while for them to figure out how
to quote unquote do your job Patriots
this'll be like five and two maybe six
and three a couple of losses that you
didn't expect I'm not saying that
they're that they're out of it I'm
saying they're gonna win the division
but it just won't be ready to be
Superbowl we'll have the topic bar at
the bottom of NFL gameday morning up
what's wrong with the Patriots and right
is this is this the end Brady you know
Curt might have an XO of like up Brady
just missed this throw and that throw is
a little off normally he makes that
throw but the phone rings it's a phone
call from a five oh eight or six one
seven area code down to the 305 hey Ron
it's T b12 that's the only way I think
he comes but it's just saw to say if
they have a poor start and Tom calls
them because you know how much he loves
Tom now if they have a poor start in
Thompson's man did you have anything
left you know Ben then maybe maybe
there's a possibility right there saying
right there oh yeah that right there
could happen but how much of a
possibility is it that we start before I
let before I just think about you or if
I just while we're on the subject did
you ever get those calls after you
retired how good how often
um from from being the first from the
Lions first season from the Lions from a
lot of teams you know teams a lot of
different teams called you walk me
through it oh I mean you'd have to talk
to my agent but I know the Dolphins
called I think me the Raiders called
yeah obviously the Lions the Lions call
they they call it you know pretty much
every other day you can see that yeah
you can see that call from your
quarterback saying come on back like
what I just painted that picture you
know no I had so many different
quarterback
that's like lunch petroi and after after
I decided you know my necklace Troy he
looked at me said Michael you really is
that it really does it so my necks broke
that's it what are you talking about
you know they it's hard they they you
know you have a relationship with those
guys you play with them and I think
that's exactly what grump will go
through at some place if it is bad for t
b12 and there and they're Patriots and
Tom calls him that would be a tough
decision for him to stay away all right
so I'll see you later tonight oh
absolutely then next week next Tuesday
is our NFL game regular season preview
show we cranked it up and no going are
we gonna get it going to it when we come
back just a chat with Barry Sanders
obviously want to talk to you about what
you thought of Andrew Luck's early
retirement since the words early
retirement and you now has a new
photograph if next to it in in the
dictionary that's Barry Sanders right
here on the Rich Eisen show Kurt Warner
also still to come with our friend Kyle
Brant from good morning football and
your phone calls at 844 204 rich number
to dial here on the show
[Music]
good to see you still sticking around
Barry Sanders good to see ya it's always
great to see a man well thank you man so
always good to see you you're one of my
you're one of my faves okay
so Andrew Luck's retirement at age 29
everyone's talking about Wow I'd say
that's the age that that Jim Brown
retired at two years before the last
technically shocking early retirement in
you what did you think of when you heard
Andrew Luck was stepping away at age 29
Barry Sanders I was surprised I was
surprised I mean obviously he's uh in
competing in the preseason not not
playing obviously but on the team and
and and around and everyone is fully
expecting him to play I had a great year
last year Comeback Player of the Year
and he's just a easy guy to root for but
but yeah I was as surprised as anyone
but I understood that you know when you
get to that point where you believe that
that's the best thing to do and and it's
something certainly something you have
to wrestle with but and I can see in his
in his press conference just you know
how difficult it was for him it's just a
tough decision you know and so it's
something I think he'll probably wrestle
with for a while I don't I don't know
the extent of his injuries but it sounds
like that had something to do with it
sure so how long did you wrestle with it
I would say I would say you know my last
season I kind of understood that going
into the offseason that that's kind of
what I was thinking and so you know
certainly a few months so so yeah I mean
it's so in my case certainly you know I
just went back and forth but and then
when as training camp came I realized
that yet I need to go ahead and make a
decision or make it known so are there
any similarities do you think between
your decision and the one that Andrew
Luck just made I mean there's some
similarities but I wasn't I wasn't
injured you know and so that really
didn't play a part of it by the way
that's amazing that a running back with
15,000 yards could say that you were not
injured
or at least significantly enough for it
to be part of your decision to walk away
the game Barry that's unbelievable it's
just just as far as leaving something
that you love that's so much a part of
you I'm sure that last season must have
been one of his most rewarding seasons
right right you know and just I think
all the promise that you know the Cotes
fans have for this upcoming season and
the potential you know I played with
Frank Reich you know he's a great guy a
great competitor you know you know coach
right so so so I can just you know
imagine you know the the just in that
locker room the anticipation for this
upcoming season for the the players and
fans so so so yeah you know it was a
tough decision to make
so Barry Sanders here in the Rich Eisen
show if the season before you decided to
walk away was similar to the one that
Andrew Luck just had would you have
walked away in a sense of how successful
they had been that's the one well I you
know it would probably probably been
tougher you know what did they they
played in the wild-card game or what
they they destroyed their division
winner in the wild-card game I mean a
boy eviscerated Houston and then got
pounded by the Patriots chief they lost
of the Chiefs my bad that's correct so
they got yeah they lost the Chiefs in
that game
I think wins and having that kind of
success I mean that's what it's all
about
right and so I think I think that would
make it tougher to walk away from them
absolutely so was it the losing I mean I
hate to drink yeah I you know cuz again
then you're you're we're all as fans
trying to come to grips how somehow
somebody that's so good rich rich I'm
sorry man
no no but how somebody who's so good if
not great at something that they clearly
loved enough to do
to the level that they were doing it
could just turn around and say you know
what life's better without it well it
was it was only better without it after
10 years of playing right and
experiencing all the things that I had a
chance to experience that that's what it
allowed me to walk away from it right
but but I think for me it was just a
situation where you know just that drive
to continue to play and the passion and
certainly losing is a part of the
experience and and that that's you know
that's part of sort of the fabric of why
you play why you exist in the game and
so like I joked earlier about you know
the many different quarterbacks and
things like that sort of you know when
you look back it was really kind of
almost kind of chaotic but and so yeah
you you play because you you think you
have the hope and the potential of being
able to to be in the history books and
certainly put together the best team
every year but for me yeah it really
just came down to that drive and desire
after 10 years but but it's certainly
not something that that I would have
ever foreseen as a young player it's
just something that happened with me and
I think it happens with you know with
players had at different times things
like that so you know that's the best
way I could explain it Barry Sanders few
more minutes left with a Hall of Famer
here on the Rich Eisen show what advice
would you have for Andrew Luck right now
as somebody who retired and shocked the
world by retiring earlier than anybody
expected well I think he's handled it
well
did one thing different for him also as
I think it sounds like he has a family
currently which I didn't have at that
time and you know answer you a question
but you know if you know Andrew I've
just met him once you know my son was
coming into Stanford as he was leaving
he talked about just a sharp
well-put-together just young man you
know who was going to do well
regardless he's gonna do well in life in
general I don't know if his degree is
engineering or architecture or whatever
um but I just I just think that he's the
type of young man that has a lot of
options well I guess that's the point of
it would be then you'd have to figure
coming to grips with it making the
announcement is the toughest part
through the toughest part unless there
is regret phone calls second thoughts
that's where I guess where the advice
might be coming in handy having you
having done this before well I think
he's going to have to decide certainly
is is this permanent right I mean I
would I wouldn't be shocked to maybe see
him give it another shot down the road
but you know like we saw with Brett
Favre not exactly the same but it's it's
a tough thing to leave and so you know
maybe maybe he heals up in a year or so
and once it give it give it another try
but but what you're asking again that's
really a personal thing you know whether
whether this is permanent whether you
know like you were talking about you
know Brady giving want to call mm-hmm
you know whether coach Reich or whoever
else whoever he's really close to T Y
Hilton if they give him the call
midseason or off next offseason or
whatever you know mr. Irsay whoever that
is and can and can maybe coach him out
of retirement you know but that's
certainly something that he's gonna have
to to deal with over over the next
couple years any of you fine I mean in
the last two minutes I have here with
you
I mean it's brought up every now pretty
much all the time with you I imagine now
that it's happened with luck it's now
brought up to you a lot more do you mind
being known as somebody retired early
from the game no no I don't mean it was
certainly a difficult time when it
happened
you know and partly just because of how
I handled it you know but but but no I
mean I I don't talk about it that much I
mean I see it as a compliment most of
the time when people bring it up to me
it's more brought up as a compliment you
know that I miss seeing you play you
know it's disappointing to see you
retire yeah that kind of thing and I you
know I mean like I said before it was it
was a tough decision to make for 29 year
old kid
you know and it's already been 20 years
since since my retirement you know but
but it's truly truly something that man
it is you just have to grapple with you
he'll continue really to have to
struggle with it and wrestle with it in
the coming days and weeks and the last
minute have with you here Frank Corson
my catcher this year Willie yeah he's
about 500 yards behind you your third
all-time
is he a hall-of-famer Frank or in your
mind um well I'll let the committee
decide that Frank has had a fantastic
career you know I'd have to look at you
know you know how many years and yards
per carry average and all that that
stuff but but but I think he will
certainly be giving great consideration
for him being in Hall of Fame you know
but if we're asking am I gonna put him
in then I you know I have to have to
take a closer look at it all right I
look like I said really appreciate you
coming on I look forward to seeing you
tonight at the NFL 100 event thanks for
coming on better to have them you were
the man at Barry Sanders on Twitter and
on Instagram I follow him you should as
well for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app